madison cawthord
quote unquote he needs to name names
of the orgy and coke partiers that he
was invited to so this is from the
freedom caucus chair basically calls
them out the new york poor story so
representative madison cotheart should
should out the fellow republicans he
claims invited him
to orgies and snorted cocaine in front
of him oh my god um
says the conservative freedom caucus
leader named scott perrier scott perry
if you're going to say something like
that you need the name name says
perry the republican from pennsylvania
hawthorne discussed alleged sexual
perversion
of some older lawmakers
including people he said he previously
looked up to
quote unquote call thorn says then all
of a sudden you get invited we're going
to have a sexual get together at our
homes you should come bro
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an orgy hi i'm madison
kawthorne i'm here for the gangbang
what is the story will you've heard this
i've heard inklings of these guys okay
you're taking you work in politics
you've heard a lot of these things
you know
i know scott perry is asking and all
this kind of stuff the left always asks
for these kind of things they say oh you
got to be this good conservative you got
to put in this good conservative box
yeah but conservatives could never ask
the left for this like when all this
stuff happened with andrew gillum who
almost won my first thought of exactly
the same
thing a government government small
amount of votes can you imagine if that
guy was our governor instead of desantis
exactly you said our governor you don't
live in florida yet sir i don't know
what you're considering cast out the bag
okay exactly soon enough
but uh
you know can you imagine if that was the
case and the conservatives don't ever
ask the left for these kind of things
they're not pressuring the left to or
the democrats to put these kind of
things out there but they will always
come and question us and try and put us
in our good little box but do you think
he's
do you think this actually happened you
think the republican older lawmakers are
inviting madison do you think that's
happening taylor i think there's some
sketchy stuff that goes on with
politicians and what they do and when
they have power what they think they can
get away with
uh yeah i would probably if i had to
like
way out probably yeah i don't know if
they're all having like
orgies and stuff like that i can't i
can't say for sure but i know that these
people do
shady weird stuff
do you think so yeah and that goes
across left right up down center
certainly yeah such as a people thing
that's just a people because again as we
talked about on the first podcast yes
they they p some people of ours next the
name some people are ds they're all the
same most of them are pretty much all
the same
the the power of politician attracts a
certain type of person
what is that type of person that type of
attraction that a type of person is a
greedy person a person who is fine with
uh sacrificing truth for what they want
and someone who doesn't care about other
people really and thinks they can get
away with things right
narcissistic type of people how do we
get these people out of politics how do
they how can politicians well it's
supposed to work then every two years
the whole government changes
the swamp in the lobbying is so bad and
corrupt that these things almost never
happen anymore because it's the money
drives the politicians yeah i don't
really think that there's a thing where
you can honestly get them out because
like
limits
that's the term limits they set the term
limit
they just gave themselves a 21 raise
people pay attention i mean honestly
scale back the federal government to the
bare bare minimum this is not how our
government is supposed to be like let
the states that can like the
have majority of the power the federal
government get out of education get out
of all these departments you need a
convention of states i mean that's
that's really what you need say it again
a convention of states what does that
mean it's kind of like a
an older idea that was in the
constitution that if they have problems
with the federal government states can
convene and do something about it
basically that's like basically the
constitution
no i know it's racist
but uh that's the basis that'll never
happen but really you're exactly right
but unfortunately that's not going to
happen and what's going to happen is
there's going to be i mean but this will
only get bigger this is only news
because it's in politics right meaning
someone invites you to a coke sex party
in south beach i'm like all right but it
should be new year
exactly exactly we're talking about
drink some whiskey but in politics it's
like holy [ __ ] what is happening but
you're saying hey it's human nature man
yeah and these people are the greediest
most self-indulgent narcissistic slimy
people out there but they put on a nice
suit comb their hair nice and and get
the attention of people so they can win
yeah
[Music]